-Let me just start by saying
that tiger was fantastic.
-I know. That tiger did
excellent work.
-Really great.
-Oh, you know what? On "9-1-1,"
we get the best animals.
-You've got the best tiger.
-We get really great animals.
-When you think about -- I mean,
you were great in that clip.
The other gentleman was great.
But the tiger
did everything perfectly.
-The tiger was perfect.
-Yeah.
-And it took a lot -- actually,
I wasn't there that day.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I was going to say.
I know how TV works. They didn't
shoot that at the same time.
-We did not shoot that
at the same time.
I was nowhere in the vicinity
of that tiger.
I had that in my contract.
-But you saw him
at the wrap party.
-I did see him
-Yeah.
-And you know what?
He was lovely.
-He was lovely!
-Oh, he's a barrel of laughs,
that tiger.
-Yeah.
-You wouldn't know it,
but that was
a really great acting --
-You know, I hope he doesn't
change because with the success
of "9-1-1," I would hate it
to go to his tiger head.
-I know. Well, he already --
you know what?
He had a little bit of a --
-He was already a little weird.
-A little bit of an entourage.
-Oh, yeah.
-A little bit
of a tiger entourage.
That was kind of scary.
-Now is a tiger's entourage
other tigers
or is it different animals?
-Well, okay. Let's see where
I can go with this.
[ Laughter ]
-So you have a -- this is nice
because you get to be
the very calm person who accepts
9-1-1 calls.
-Right, mm-hmm.
-Are you -- do you think you
would be good if it happened
in real life?
-I mean, I have no idea.
I would literally never,
ever be doing that job
in real life.
-Yeah.
-I mean, there's just no
question about that in my mind.
So I don't know how I would be.
I would probably -- I really
honestly don't know,
if I'm completely honest.
-Yeah.
-I can't imagine what I would do
if I'm instructing a person
who's about to be attacked
by a tiger...
-Yeah.
-...what they should be doing.
No idea.
-Yeah.
I would have said the opposite.
I'd be like, "you got to --
he's as afraid of you
as you are of him."
[ Laughter ]
"You got to run at that tiger."
-He's -- I would say --
"He smells your fear."
That's a thing, right?
-Yeah, I would --
oh, that's a good thing.
-They definitely smell --
they smell your fear.
-That's a real good one.
-That's what I should have said.
-Yeah.
-That's what I would say --
That's would Connie would say.
-Also a lot of the advice
sometimes are, like,
not helpful.
It's like, "do you have any pots
and pans to bang?"
[ Laughter ]
That's what I would say.
I'm like, "Get your pots
and pans."
-Yeah.
-And you're like,
"I'm at the zoo."
-They hate pots and pans.
Ugh! You don't have any.
That's so hard.
-I would then blame them.
I'd say, "Don't leave --
"I know now's not the time,
but don't leave the house
without your pots and pans."
-I know, right?
It's like, "what were you
thinking this morning?"
-"What were you thinking?"
-"What were you thinking?
Don't go to the zoo like that."
-Did you visit
an actual 9-1-1 call center
before --
-I thought you were going to say
"Did you visit an actual zoo?"
-Did you go to a zoo?
-No, no, we've already been
through that.
-Have you been to a zoo?
They're fantastic.
-I -- no, they're so great.
-They're so great.
They have all the animals.
-So many animals there.
-You know and they're from all
parts of the world,
so instead of having --
-Kind of like our wrap party.
-Yeah, exactly.
-With the entourage.
-The entourage, right.
He had a koala, an otter --
-Right, he did.
-Did you go there,
to a call center?
-Oh, yes, I went to several --
I went to the call center
several times.
-Oh, it was helpful.
-The call center -- it was --
oh, are you kidding?
If I actually were capable of
doing that job, I would be
so much smarter than I am.
-Are they all super smart?
-They're all so smart.
They're all incredibly
well trained.
They have six computer screens
in front of them,
all with very different things
going on all the time.
-Like one's their emails
and the other's like --
-Right, like, no, exactly.
Porn site.
-"Uh-huh? Hold on, what?
I'm sorry,
I'm in an eBay bidding war."
[ Laughter ]
-I know, they really --
they don't take it
very seriously at all.
-But you did...